champion skier bode miller and his wife
Morgan are renewing their warning to
parents about the dangers of drowning
after the loss of their young daughter
according to the American Academy of
Pediatrics drowning is a top cause of
death for one to four year old children
new guidance says that swim lessons can
actually help kids after the age of one
and home pools need to be surrounded by
4-foot fencing and a locked gate the
Millers and Nicole Hughes whose child
also drowned are teaming up with the
Academy for a series of public service
announcements that you'll see first on
CBS this morning so we went to
California for a behind-the-scenes look
the bond between Nicole Hughes and
Morgan Miller is forged in grief for the
past year the two mothers have leaned on
each other from across the country we
watched it we were good at in a parent
as they've navigated an unthinkable
journey Morgan and her husband Olympic
skier Bode Miller lost their daughter
Emmy last June after the 19 month old
slipped out of a neighbor's house and
drowned in a swimming pool that same day
Nicole's three year old son Levi also
drowned after he wandered outside during
a family vacation
I'm Bodhi Miller and this is my wife
Morgan in Southern California the
families channeled their grief into
action partnering with the American
Academy of Pediatrics to alert other
parents to the dangers of drowning my
son Levi was so proud to turn 3 but he
will never get the chance to turn 4 I
never thought my child would drown but I
was wrong drowning is the single leading
cause of death and children ages 1 to 4
we believe it should be the number one
thing parents think about when it comes
to safety as a mom I want other parents
to know how fast drowning can happen it
takes moments you have to be vigilant as
if it's a line waiting to Snatcher child
dr. ben hoffman of the AAP says the two
families are making an impact the
courage with which they've approached
this and their willingness to share has
really allowed us to communicate the
issue in a very different way
while honoring the children they lost
both families are celebrating new
editions the Millers are savoring every
milestone with their 7 month old son
Easton and the Hughes family is
expecting a baby girl very soon very
soon bode miller and Nicole Hughes join
us first on CBS this morning
good morning to you both Nicole what is
very soon mean expecting a few a
congratulations Bodhi to you in Morgan
because you're also expecting a baby too
coming up thank you so Congrats
but let's talk about this because it's
that time of year when parents are
starting to think about swimming you to
endure many of the most painful things
that a parent's can go through and you
decided you're going to turn that pain
into this what do you want us to know
about this new announcement I think both
of our tragedies happen not during swim
time and this this time of year it's
been winter certainly on the East Coast
but even in California was kind of a
glum time not a lot of kids in the pool
and parents aren't thinking that and you
know kids are crafty and they get out
fast and this whole process I think the
the terrifying part about this time of
year is you know that the kids are
thinking it before the parents are and
and that non swim time for me I think
we've hit on you know it happens quick
and it happens when you're not swimming
you weren't cooking or you're you know
and the kids gone for that amount of
time and and you're left with a lifetime
of sort of regret and it happened so
quickly to Nicole I remember it stuck
it's stuck in my mind I use it you would
started eating a brownie and you never
even got a chance to finish the brownie
that's how quickly it happened it was so
fast yeah you know and you think there's
time and you think that it's not going
to happen to you I mean nobody thinks
it's going to be you
I'm a good parent yeah guys and I was
wearing khaki shorts so you'd had a bath
he was sitting on the couch and he
slipped out of a room filled with people
including both parents and so what what
can parents do to instead of feelings
hurt hunted by the fact that they always
have to be watching them you guys are
helping people know what to do ahead of
time well I think you know we we've all
sort of attacked this as a team I mean
aap has been amazing and the
there is a certain picture not having
car seats picture not having seatbelts
in your car before that I mean these are
things that like we're sort of an
evolution of safety and there's a bunch
of stuff coming out right now I'm
working with them excited to launch it
in the market right now that we're
parents can't watch a piece of water you
know a pool all the time it's just not
realistic to think we all would love to
believe we could be there every moment
but that I think is the next step is
these products that you know coral
detection systems things that are able
to monitor a pool 100% of the time use
machine learning AI that both of our
situations would have been entirely
different if we'd had this device that's
on the market right now it honestly
wasn't on the market at that point which
is obviously frustrating for us but I
think we're making enough noise and
there's enough need there that we're
gonna make these steps really quickly
and hopefully you know change this
there's those technological things that
can happen like you just mentioned
you're a new thing that you're launching
obviously the fence around the pool
those kinds of things but then also I
know the American Academy of Pediatrics
also has some guidelines about swim
lessons and I know we visited you out
there to watch you with your son doing
some swim lessons when does that start
how early can you start what can you do
it you will you know Levi there and
there were zero layers of protection I
mean there wasn't a four-sided fence
there there was a momentary lapse when I
turn to close a bag of Cheetos and he
got away and he didn't know how to save
himself in the water and the survival
swim lessons to focus on water
competency I mean that's that since Emmy
and Levi's both didn't drown at our
houses like the survival swim lessons
are a skill we can bring you know with
us somewhere else that's I think I think
that's that moving the AAP moving as
quickly as they did and as decisively to
move the the agedama was I think it was
it was four before to move that so
decisively down to one-year-old and I
think ours are six month olds Jesus
there are six month old is supply is
learning now it's been floated for its
first time which i think is really you
know it gives us that peace of mind and
Nicole the PSA you did also focuses on
pediatricians yes I mean you know I
think that that is of course we trusted
loved our pediatrician so much and the
AAP has such a powerful platform but for
them to be able to say hey
let's talk to parents and really
emphasize this as much as we are
emphasizing corvex I mean drowning is
just as deadly and just as preventable
as car accidents and as you know these
illnesses so if we could just approach
it with that same urgency and that thing
that is 100% preventable you can keep
your child yeah if they always say that
there's always a silver lining to a
tragedy there to me there's no silver
lining when you lose a child what is the
best way we can look at this Bodhi how
the two of you have managed to move
forward what is your message Europe
yeah I mean I think you know I agree
with you there's no silver lining here
but but you know you you keep going I
think for both of our families there was
really no alternative this was something
that look we have other kids that depend
on us we have stuff and well you
continue to suffer being able to direct
your your sort of suffering into
productive things it's helpful you can't
hide I mean I think all of us would love
to have just hid and like you know but
that process of being out there and you
know trying to make a difference I think
it does it gives you a sense of
community I mean we're trying we're
doing it for other people really at this
point you know but it's not so not to
say that it couldn't happen to us again
which is a horrifying thought but you
know you have to make these changes you
have to really be vigilant and I think
that's you know ultimately it's a
responsibility as a human being but it's
a tough one sometimes to take on we're
grateful yes honestly we are grateful
because we need these reminders and
everybody needs help it's a community
that raises children thank you thank you
buddy you call always thinking of you
and your families to see more of the
PSAs and define the American Academy of
Pediatrics advice on how to prevent
drowning go to our website CBS this
morning calm